United Nations Secretary General Antonio
gutiz is vowing to take action against
any un employee involved in quote acts
of Terror this comes after allegations
by Israel that some unrust staffers were
involved in the October 7th Hamas attack
that killed nearly 1200 people in a
statement released Sunday gutterz also
promised a review of the United Nations
relief and works Agency for Palestine
refugees however he called on
governments to continue supporting the
UN body after at least nine countries
including Canada paused funding since
the start of the Gaza War more than 2.3
million Palestinians have been relying
on Aid provided by unra every un body
has become weaponized against the Jewish
State exploited as an instrument to Aid
in the elimination of my
people how symbolic it is how symbolic
is it that on International Holocaust
Remembrance Day it was exposed osed that
anra employees took part in the
massacre the Israeli war against anura
is not
new Israel has all the time been calling
for the liquidation and dismantling of
the
anara and this explains the Israeli
systematic attack on refugee camps
whether in Gaza or here in the West Bank
the accusations that Israel has made
against certain St of the anura should
have waited until investigation has come
up with results we were extremely
shocked that certain number of countries
have decided to suspend its Aid or their
aid for the anara the countries that
have announced this suspension their aid
amounts to 70% of the annual budget of
the United Nation relief and work agency
this measure is extremely dangerous and
it is our our hope that it will be
reversed this step Sim simultaneously
taken during the war in as sends a wrong
message this this is there is a war
against the Palestinian people this
decision is incorrect and should be
stopped immediately we urge all these do
all these countries to repay the ownera
because it's a humanitarian issue it it
has been taken in a long time and we
hope that they will come back soon to
understand that the need of the the
people in Gaza and everywhere is a
necessity for continuing living on this
Earth
for
un suffers from chronic underfunding
which impact the quality of our
services upholding refugees right is not
only the responsibility of humanitarian
and Development actors it is a
responsibility shared with donors and
host
countries